the wrestling started like as kind of a
like a Carney type of a sport in the 30s
and and there's certain things that are
so you know primitive are you a member
of sag I am but not through wrestling no
I know but the SAG so sag doesn't come
after you I know I've seen uh terrifying
too terrifier too yeah terrifier too so
you are uh one of the few people that
has had childhood dreams and more than
one childhood dream and kind of
accomplished all your dreams you know
kids sitting at home watching wrestling
watching Hulk Hogan boom he's in the
ring yeah you know watching Ozzy
Osbourne boom you got that gold record
right loving horror horror films boom
you're in horror films yeah those movies
have really taken off somebody was
telling me uh Jeremy was telling me
before that uh you know that's made it
it's like they're crowdfunding movies
right so terrifier two
um yeah it was crowdfunded I think the
budget was 250 thousand dollars over 8
million now it's over 8 million I think
it's gonna top out at 10. and it's got
the buzz from like those movies of the
70s like watch this movie at your own
risk people are puking and passing out
in the theaters beware it's incredible
and once you get that word of mouth you
can't stop it right what's happening
we're spreading it right now right now
right here so go you've seen it it's
disgusting it's super gross I've seen a
lot of disgusting things okay it's
another clown art the cloud yeah
I don't know Arthur clown uh if you saw
me be creeped out you'd be terrified I
know Centipede Human Centipede humans
yeah this is not the same movie you
don't want it you don't want to be in
that I don't know I don't want to be in
the middle or team sure really you want
to be at any side of that well the front
wouldn't be as bad I don't think if
you're going to be in the human
centipede it's best to be in the front I
I think there's a word of it guys
there's your click bait headline for the
show if you're going to be in centipede
be the front guy only if you could
choose who's the second
okay that works that works out yes
that's the caveat you don't want Gene
Simmons to be number two you'll end up
choking let's pitch it celebrity
centipede every Tuesday night at seven
on ABC on ABC you're right it is very
different it would take it yes
[Music]